Dot dot dot dot dot dot dot dot...
Transformers.
Okaerinasaimase!
Goshujinjamou!
Jijjamou!
Hello, everybody!
Hello, it is I.
Mint Franto.
And we're back with Transformers Devastation.
Hey!
Minky in disguise.
Hey, yeah!
It's a bit of an early stream for me today.
If it's Friday for you, happy Friday.
If it's Saturday for you, happy Saturday.
If it's Thursday for you...
Anyway...
We're gonna get into it.
It's my birthday tomorrow!
Can I get a happy early birthday from my favorite freaky ghost?
Since you're not streaming tomorrow.
Actually...
I am doing a double stream tomorrow!
Actually, I got asked to...
I was gonna do a...
A membership stream tomorrow.
So I could have one before I went to Japan.
But then...
I also got asked for a sponsored stream.
Like, last minute.
Finalized this morning.
Actually, it's not even final finalized.
But...
Yeah!
So...
I will have that...
Yeah.
Release webis and time travelers.
I got sponsored.
I don't think I can say...
Just what exactly yet.
But I think it's pretty darn cool.
So...
Meetup twice in one day!
Yippee!
Oh my gosh, eating Toki bird's ass!
Look at that!
I'm back!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thanks last time too!
Rasta Monster, welcome to membership!
Blue Viking, welcome back!
Vtuber Lurker on site.
Lurker.
I'm such a lurker.
I don't talk in chats.
So I'm just like...
I don't know, if everybody were like me...
What would I even talk about?
I guess I would yap to myself.
But anyway, Raymac...
I guess I could...
Do you want me to wait?
For tomorrow, or...
Lurker here, it's true.
Lurker!
Domingo, thanks for 10 months!
Fixy, thanks for 9 months!
But...
Yeah.
Sorry, I got all distracted.
I got all distracted.
But...
We're here.
Transformers Devastation.
I don't wanna yap too much, because I wanna be like...
Are you gonna do birthday songs during sponsored streams?
No, but...
Like I said, I'm doing a double stream.
So...
I'm double streaming.
God, I said your birthday don't know again.
Yeah, great!
Thank you for the 500, thank you!
Santina, welcome back!
Take care of your voice.
Yeah, but I'm gonna be gone for a week, so...
I figured I should...
I should...
Well, a little bit over a week.
So I was like, I should...
I should not take a break.
Thanks for the 500!
Mimi, thanks for one month!
Here are some canonical transformers.
Erector.
Who nearly won an official fan vote for the hall of fame.
Dickbot, the blender guy.
And the breastforced breastformers.
I'm looking these guys up.
Every single one of them right now.
Hold on.
This is big news.
This is the big, big news.
Wait.
Erector.
Transformers.
Oh, wait.
No.
That's not what he actually...
Wait.
No.
And then, Dickbot.
The blender guy.
Whoops.
I spelled that all wrong.
Dickbot.
What the hell?
This guy is insane looking.
Oh my god.
Why...
Ew, I'm getting like other things.
Okay, I don't wanna...
Scroll in Google too long.
And then, breast...
Force...
Where are the...
Where are they?
Thank you.
Current HasLab campaign.
They combined them two.
Those are words I don't know.
Breastforce Doka.
Breastforce Coco.
Aoi Mori, thank you so much for the 5 gifted.
Take a break from watching your vibes for hours to be here.
This better be freaky.
I mean, we are talking about breastforce right now.
I mean...
Breast...
Wait, what was it called?
Breastforce...
Breastformers.
Hi Mint.
Hello Imanol.
Ally, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Ducky, thanks for the gifted.
Okay.
Shall we play?
I can't...
Get over how cool Optimus Prime sounds.
He's just such a...
He's just got such an iconic voice.
It's...
It's just the voice that I always want to hear all the time.
Like, I want...
I want...
I want Peter Cullen to narrate novels so I can fall asleep to them.
Hello Minta, I'm 28 since yesterday.
Old oof.
Old oof!
Happy birthday, Angel!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Angel Gill.
Happy birthday!
Thanks for the gifted.
The breastforce can have their breastplates attached to form animal drones.
For their new figures this year, Hasbro called them the chestforce.
What?
Why?
I mean, does it make it that much better?
Alright, I'm gonna have to remember how to play this game.
So, let's continue.
And we're gonna go, go, go, baby, until there is no more to go.
Until we're all done.
What's the plan, Optimus?
Bimbobee!
He's so cute!
First time chatter.
This game is quite literally labeled pink.
Thanks for the superchat.
Decepti-creep.
Split up and find a Decepticon.
Okay, a single Decepticon.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, we're finding...
Find a Decepticon.
That's right, we went into here.
And it was like kind of insane.
And like there was...
Okay, alright, it's like this.
Nope, this.
Open up.
There we go.
And here.
Nice.
Drill Nuts from Japanese Beast War.
Thank you guys for all the superchats!
The Breast Force's leader is called Deathsaurus.
He's a big metal chicken monster.
Boobs.
Gobots.
No.
Alright, hold on.
This is how to aim.
And I think R1 is to shoot, but I don't want to waste energy.
And then we can switch stuff.
We'll do our drills, Devastator's Drills.
And then this is Heavy Attack.
And this is Light Attack, Jump.
What was Circle?
I don't remember.
I guess we'll figure it out.
And thank you Joshua for the dono.
Did you hear about the new horror film that came out today called The Monkey?
Oh my gosh, I haven't stopped seeing trailers for it, to be honest.
It's based off a Stephen King novel, but I don't know the novel at all.
Oh, Circle is...
And then we can...
Throw!
Wait!
That actually worked.
Hold on.
If we get more cars...
And lift...
And throw...
At these things...
Just kidding.
I can't aim.
It's fine.
We can run through this.
Easy peasy.
We're gonna go find...
A Decepticon.
There's one.
Hot dog.
Hot dog indeed.
Mintotron.
I met you at Vexpo last year.
The guy from Iceland.
Yeah, I remember!
I said you were probably my only fan from Iceland.
I was originally there for a Transformers convention that was happening at the same time.
It's awesome that you're playing this game.
Shut up!
Yeah!
Wait.
Sorry.
Oh gosh, I don't want to waste my...
Wait, who am I hearing?
Oh, you!
Oh my gosh.
Pick up!
Come here!
Okay, I got him.
We're fine.
Probably.
Down.
Wait, am I supposed to talk?
I found a Decepticon.
That scared me.
That's my money.
My money!
Wait, my money!
Okay.
Ouch.
Ouchy ouch.
We can just run through here, right?
We don't have to be so badass and cool all the time.
Okay, nice.
Proud star.
Information.
This thing...
Oh my gosh.
What?
Oh, dang it.
We killed his ass.
We got it.
Stupid baby is dead.
Shoot those laser things too.
Also, in your inventory you probably have some capsules that give permanent stat boost.
Oh, I do?
Oh, there's this thing.
Nice.
Hold on, it's gonna take me like a little second to get back used to the game, guys.
So, sorry if I'm a little stupid for a minute.
Wait.
No!
Oh shoot.
Kill, kill, kill!
Alright.
Dang it.
This is the claw, man.
Oh shoot.
Yeah!
Alright, number two down.
Oh my gosh.
This is just absolute chaos here.
It's just absolute...
Oops.
My auto-aim.
Oh, I thought we were gonna aim onto this guy.
Yeah!
This guy!
I wonder if they ever stop coming.
Stop coming and I don't stop coming and I don't stop coming.
Collect my loot and my...
Alright, come here, come here.
Take that.
Deceptiscum.
This was a thing we did before.
These were the generators.
Generators.
Don't call it a fart attack!
That's much more sophisticated.
No?
Nice.
And...
Oh, no, no.
Okay.
I will.
I'll get him.
Don't worry about it.
Catch Thundercracker.
Tell you the location of the core.
Okay.
Hey buddy!
What was that?
Oops.
Wait, hold on.
Hold on, let me redo.
Redo, redo.
Where did he go anyway?
Thundercracker!
Where'd he go?
Where am I going?
I lost you.
I need your location, please.
Thundercracker, hold on.
I'm farming.
I'm looting.
Thank you.
Where's your location?
Oh, wait.
Oh, there's something over there.
Let's go check it out.
Oh, my gosh.
Thank you guys for all the superchats.
It's so hard to read them though.
You guys!
Thank you!
But it's so hard to read while I'm playing.
Remember that in the IDW comics, Thundercracker is a Hollywood screenwriter and he has a dog named Buster.
What?
If you want others...
Oh, yeah, everybody...
Oh, my gosh.
I've got a bajillion comments about the war for Cybertron.
So, let's see about playing it.
What the...
Maybe nothing here.
Did I get it already?
Weird.
Okay, I'm lost.
Thank you for the superchats!
Okay, maybe...
Where do I go?
Okay, this looks like the track.
Okay.
Alright, we're back in business, baby.
We're back in business.
Alright, Thundercracker, don't go.
Thundercracker.
We gotta find Thundercracker.
We gotta get him to spill his secrets, spill his guts to us.
What?
This is a dead end.
This way.
Oh, wait, how do I...
How do I destroy this again?
Uh...
How do I destroy this thing again?
Was it through the car?
It says it's Thundercracker's birthday.
How do I get to him?
Where the heck is this guy?
Oh my god, dead end.
Car mode into attack.
Okay, okay.
Right now though, we have another goal.
Sick!
There he is!
No, he's not!
Where the hell?
Oh my god, there he is!
Son of a bitch.
Where did he go?
This way.
Sick flip, bro.
Yeah, get his ass!
Where is he?
Uh, he's somewhere.
He's...
Over...
I'm running in...
Over here?
I got him, I got him.
Yeah!
He scared the hell out of me.
Thundercracker!
I got an A on that, by the way.
You can't just say that, Bumblebee!
You can't just call him that!
Oh my gosh.
Liberty Bridge.
Thank you for the...10 Captain!
Thank you!
Alright.
Plasma Core.
This game is so wild.
I'm not seeing anything.
Wait, am I going the wrong way?
Hello?
No, it has to be this way.
Right?
Oh yeah, it's gotta be that way.
Alright.
Sorry for everybody's cars!
I hope you have insurance!
Wait!
Here!
Yellow dot.
I know, I'm just...
Directionally...
You know...
Something.
Thunder Honkey.
Thundercracker is usually a Decepticon sympathetic to humans.
Questioning his loyalties.
Also, his final appearance in IDW has him attending the Oscars as a nominee for his film about G.I.
Joe!
Why does he question his loyalty?
Nice!
I think we're good.
Yeah.
Alright.
Anything...
Oh, there's more down here!
Trying to get all the good loot and all.
If they're guarded, surely they're better.
Okay, hold on.
Oh!
I can do it!
Yeah!
No!
Got it!
Okay.
Oh wait, I still need this.
We're going!
You may need vehicle insurance.
No!
Oh!
Woo!
Hello!
Did I kill everybody?
I think I did.
My money!
Road Rage.
If you have Road Rage, you should play this game.
Because...
Honestly...
It feels good to just drive into everything.
It feels good.
I'm not gonna lie.
How am I supposed to get this one?
Maybe.
Hold on.
Sorry for being loot goblin!
Yeah!
Alright.
Nice.
This way.
Oh shit!
I can't see anything.
But I know I'm doing everything.
Oh my god!
How do you expect me to make that jump?
Wait, hold on.
We can do this.
Hi Bob!
Oh, it's been a while.
Hey!
Hi buddy.
Wait!
I went the wrong way.
Do Transformers get car insurance or life insurance?
Well, like...
How do they get tired and stuff?
Like when they're fighting...
When they're fighting and they get tired...
Why?
What is your battery low?
Oh come on.
I literally missed every single one.
I missed all of them!
They eat Energon.
Oh, they gotta eat the Energon.
Oh, that's right.
So close.
Okay, I give up.
Alright, let's keep going.
But before...
We do that.
We're gonna enter in here.
Wait.
Someone said...
How do I know in my items if I have...
If I have permanent upgrade stuff?
What would it be?
Temporarily, temporarily, temporarily, temporarily...
Raises speed by one?
Raises endurance by one.
What's wrong with my intelligence?
Ah?
Enhance.
Oh, these too?
Oh, these are temp though.
Minky low intelligence?
No.
Should we play?
I don't wanna...
Use items.
I kinda wanna try playing as Grimlock.
I'm not gonna lie.
But...
I wonder if he'll be too slow.
He's fine?
I imagine.
I believe it.
Did I get anything good?
No, everything's bad.
Okay.
Let's see.
We can give him a tech.
He can only have one tech.
And we have quite a bit.
Let's see.
Ultimate move, attack up.
You know what?
Let's just give him the best that we got, baby.
Oh, look how cute he is!
He's a little stumped, but that's okay.
Me Grimlock.
I could develop more tech.
We'll save on it though.
I feel like we should probably buy...
Some good weapons eventually.
Oh my gosh, 180,000!
He's fine.
He's a wrestler.
He's dumb.
He's my son.
It's Gucci.
Me Grimlock.
Okay, ready?
Let's try.
Let's try Grimlock.
He's too cute!
When using Grimlock, dodge with perfect timing and press...
Oh, that's right.
Okay, dodge is R1, I think.
And press circle to grapple and toss enemies.
You can also accelerate in his dino mode by tapping circle repeatedly.
Alright, wait.
Oh, never mind.
We're in the cutscene.
Well, if I don't know Grimlock now, I'm gonna learn.
Ground soldier.
Here we go!
I did not... Oh, maybe I did.
Tap,
tap, tap, tap, tap, tap!
Tap, tap, tap!
Oh my god, look how fast he is!
This is so scary!
Warning?
Warning.
What's the warning?
Oh, that's the warning.
Okay.
Nice!
I didn't know how to grapple though.
Oh shit, okay.
I don't know how to grapple.
Oh my god.
Maybe because he's too chunky?
Holy cow.
Guy is too beefy maybe.
There's something at the top of the bridge.
See that?
It said circle though, right?
Like I could circle munch them?
Look at him go!
He's zooming!
He's so cute!
I think I might have...
Okay.
L1 in robot mode.
Oh, L1 in ro... Okay.
Use Energon cubes to break through Decepticon defenses.
Okay.
Oh, why?
Why am I in suddenly top-down mode?
What the hell is this?
What is this?
Why?
I can't see shit.
I can't see anything.
Pick up that.
I got it, I think.
Not this way.
I got it?
This is so bizarre.
Okay.
We'll go get this one first, I suppose.
If I can see...
Wait, this way?
Okay.
Back to bridge.
Hell yeah.
Oh, come on!
Can I throw it at them?
Oh, yeah.
That was good.
I think you can't even get a single attack in.
Bozos.
Alright, I'm lifting and I'm bringing it back.
I'm bringing it back.
Stupid!
Okay, hold on.
Shoot.
No, hold on.
I gotta tap.
I gotta run.
Oh, no?
It's not good enough?
Okay, hold on.
I thought it would be...
I thought it would be good enough to, like, destroy them, you know?
Even that's not good enough to...
No!
Loser!
I'm getting hit too in the process.
How am I supposed to defeat these things?
Oh my gosh.
Throw!
Okay, that got one at least.
It's tricky when I can't go into this crazy card mode.
Alright, we're going back.
Okay.
My health could be better, but we'll just make it work.
We got this.
Oh my god.
I have a better idea.
We'll bring more.
We'll bring lots of it, you know?
We don't need just one.
We can get more!
And then we'll throw them all at once.
Can you pick multiple up at once?
No, it doesn't seem to be the case.
Get more of them.
My last one disappeared!
This is messed up!
No way!
My genius plan thwarted!
Seriously?
Despawn.
Maybe go next to the five captain.
Thank you.
You didn't believe hard enough.
No!
But we do have a ult.
So I'm gonna see what that does.
First I'm gonna throw.
I'm gonna go get another one.
Nice throw.
Thank you.
Alright.
Yeah.
Now...
The other one should have despawned, right?
And now...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Now I can retry.
Throw!
Wow!
Oh my god!
I didn't mean to do that!
That's what L1 does.
It's pretty spooky.
Wait, can I do this one at a time?
Desert Trisky, thank you so much for 6 bucks.
Here we go!
OK, who's next?
I don't feel like doing it four more times.
OK, I get in close.
And...
Oh, that didn't do nearly as much as I thought it would!
No!
Oh my gosh, wait.
I can't get through!
I'm trying to jump over these guys.
Oh my gosh.
No, stop!
OK, anyway.
I'm doing this again.
Oh, ouch.
Take that, take that.
No, take this, take this.
Take it, take it.
And...
Hit!
There we go.
OK, I got him.
I think.
Oh gosh.
What do I...
Crimzeek!
OK.
Nice swing.
We got it in the end.
It worked somehow.
Somehow it worked.
Can I transform while I'm carrying it?
No.
Get them chompers working.
Oh my god.
From top down, this is too much!
Throw!
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
I'm trying to lift it.
Run, run, Grimlock, run, run!
Throw!
Crimzeek!
Dino attack!
Just kidding.
Who's next?
Who wants to fight me next?
Why doesn't this work?
Oh, there he is.
Dino attack!
Just kidding.
Grab it, grab it, grab it, grab it, grab it.
Oh no, shoot.
Grab, grab.
And...
Oh shoot.
I didn't dodge fast enough.
Dino attack!
Oh my gosh, I keep pressing L1 instead because I'm a big old bozo.
There we go.
I love it when he waddles.
He's so cute.
I just don't know.
Maybe if I pick it up.
Maybe if I hit it with like this.
Really?
Even though this thing is so powerful?
It doesn't work?
Whatever.
Explode it.
Oh, you're so right.
I didn't even think about that.
I was exploding everything but the one.
Hi Starscream.
This guy is such a weasel.
Oh my gosh.
You...
Where is he?
I'm running.
Where are you?
Get his ass.
Oh damn.
He's so sneaky.
He's so fast.
Where'd he go?
There he is.
Come on.
I almost tried to...
I'm gonna need to heal soon.
Wait, hold on.
Oh wait, I heal...
Actually, we can always just do the fight again.
This restores 50% of health.
It's not bad.
Whatever, we'll just do the fight again.
F break for you.
Oh my gosh.
Time to die.
Uh oh, I'm low on...
Oh no, I'm getting stun locked.
Stupid...
I'm out.
Did I know it?
Oh my gosh.
What's happening?
I got something.
I got a trophy for something.
He's so close.
Where is he?
Come here.
I got him.
I got him!
Another day out of...
Look at him scratching his head.
I still think, I'm not gonna lie guys, I still think I fight better with Bumblebee.
I did a little doom scrolling with this stream in the background.
I finally get a mint clip recommended on Instagram.
But it's you talking about hentai and java... What?
Oh, sorry Grimlock.
I still think I feel most comfortable switching in and out with Bumblebee.
Grimlock, I'm sorry.
Ready, ready, ready.
Here we go.
Oh,
it's open.
Let's swing.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
I'm aiming with what?
What was that?
I said F.
Oh my god.
Ouch.
I thought that was you dying.
I didn't think that was an attack.
Oh, ouchie ouch.
Oh god.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
That was trap.
Okay, come on, come on, come on.
Strife!
Oh gosh, Ryo.
Ryo, strife.
I missed something glowy.
I'm sad about that.
Can you get back low again?
How do I aim?
Oh, there's the aim.
I see it now.
Oh gosh.
Oh my god.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
You're okay buddy.
Oh, I can attack like that too.
Come on, come on, Bumblebee.
Oh, it's R2.
I'm trying to aim.
Aim.
There we go.
Oh my god, I ran right into him.
I hate this.
I hate sequences like this.
My depth perception, please.
I can't tell where you are at.
I can't tell.
I can't tell where I'm at.
I'm just gonna keep holding down.
Ouch, I didn't even see that.
There we go.
He's almost there.
We're almost there.
Bumblebee, you good?
Oh gosh.
So
close.
Oh my god.
The longest bridge in history.
Bumblebee.
I did not think I was gonna be able to do that first try.
I'm not gonna lie.
That's it.
Auto scum.
Help!
Where is he?
Oh gosh.
I almost got my back attacked.
Where the hell did you come from?
I'm just trying to dodge, man.
Oh
my god, what's happening?
This is so unfair.
You can be a...
Ouch.
I'm getting my ass kicked.
Come on.
There we go.
How do you have ice magic too?
I'm out.
Oh no.
Nice.
Okay.
I accidentally switched to the...
You gotta be kidding with that.
He's so close.
My health.
What the hell?
Oh my god.
I'm about to fall into the...
Let's you die between people's legs so you can back attack them?
Really?
I'll have to try it.
Oh yeah, guys.
Wearing Megatron's helmet.
Nah.
He didn't make a doodoo.
He just grabbed it with the claws.
C's get degrees, everybody.
C's get degrees.
Wait.
I met Bumblebee's VA at a con a few years back.
His ex-wife and my sister had the same name.
Getting an autograph was...
That's not... It's not...
Your fault.
Yay.
Alright, Bumblebee.
Do we want to give you Starscream's...
Starscream's...
This is the cryo machine gun.
Hold on.
How good...
It wasn't this.
What was it?
Starscream... This one.
Oh no.
It's not a better.
Starscream sucks.
His null ray is not as good as my current thing.
Wait.
Let's see with the cryo machine gun.
This is even worse.
Hold on.
My head is kind of blocking it.
There you go.
It's even worse.
This stuff is too good.
Starscream... That guy is such a weasel.
He's always just like...
One day...
One day, Megatron, I'll betray you.
He's just a weaselly guy.
You can always upgrade stuff.
That's true.
That is true.
Synthesize everything.
Gosh, there's so much going on in this game.
Swap out the dual swords.
Maybe...
Actually, let's see.
It has less attack power.
Hold on, guys.
I'm so sorry.
How long has it been?
Oh my gosh.
It hasn't even been an hour.
But I have to go to the little ghost's room.
I'm sorry.
I've been drinking so much water today.
I'll be right back.
Usually, I'm at the two hour mark.
But today...
I'm at the one hour mark.
Everybody stay hydrated, okay?
Okay, BRB.
BRB.
I'm back.
A delivery.
Right when I...
left.
So, good timing for me.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
I am back.
I'm back, baby!
Okay, we'll do Starscream's little...
little things.
But everything requires Energon.
Does it all require its own Energon?
Or if I'm once I'm out of Ener...
Oh, no.
Because I ran out of Energon on the cryo machine gun...
and then I was able to use the Energon for this one.
Okay.
We're so back.
But I'm keeping Devastator's drills...
because those...
What?
Yeah.
Well, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Okey-dokey.
I feel so bad, you guys.
I'm sorry.
I feel that I haven't been able to really...
reach out so much with this game.
But hopefully, you guys don't mind so much.
I feel like you guys are all being like...
I'm trying to tell Mint the cool lore.
And I'm like...
I play game.
Oh, yeah, we were gonna synthesize.
Let's see.
Yeah, it's action game.
I gotta lock in.
I gotta be like...
I am enjoying the game.
We could synthesize...
with like a baby.
Stupid stuff.
With the gloves.
Mr.
Beast?
No!
I think we decided if I had a beast form...
I would be a monkey.
Beast or beast.
A mist?
Mist would be...
Probably useful for sneaking in places.
Remember chat, wise man once said...
It is better to be pissed on than pissed off.
I think it might have been Confucius or something.
Beethoven, look at us!
I'm not looking.
I'm ignoring.
Attack level 2.
Wait, cryo gloves?
No, no.
Wait, no, no.
Wait, what did I...
Wait, synthesize?
Oh, Devastator's Drills.
Okay, there we go.
I was like, wait a second.
Stupid.
What's one with like a special...
Something or other, you know?
Bolt?
Bolt, wreck, plus?
What's that mean?
Item pull level 3?
That's pretty good actually.
I can only do one though.
Oh wait, do I already have one of these?
Select skills to be...
I gotta pick two.
These are the ones that I already have, right?
Minky triple changer.
Cute ghost maid who becomes a funny monkey or a mint chocolate chip ice cream cone.
The red is the equipped ones.
Okay, nevermind.
Maybe let's see if we have any other skills that are really good that we could...
Energon attack plus.
Okay.
Item pull.
Sorry, outspeed.
What's wreck drop?
Attack plus.
Accuracy?
I don't need that.
I'm 100% accurate.
Knockdown?
Okay, okay.
I lost my place.
No, focus.
Bolt cost?
Minus?
That could be pretty good actually.
That could be pretty good maybe.
My friend said your transformer's alt mode would be a cute little steam train.
Wait, I love that!
Love that.
Can you give us your best...
Autobots, transform and roll out!
Fire rate, overdrive, knockdown plus.
I don't know, but there's so many things that we could do.
That was great?
You think so?
I'm pretty good?
Yeah, I want to be a train.
Okay, what are the things that we...
Oh, there was one that I was gonna do.
Not the focus.
Unless focus would be good because I do dodge a lot and kind of like, you know...
And it's level 4 focus!
Hold on.
Increases damage dealt by 15% mid-focus.
Wait, that's kind of huge!
Increases recovery rate of the ultimate gauge by 8%.
Increases the amount of health recovered by 6%.
15% is a lot, no?
That's what the new steampunk bubble beat turns into?
No way!
Health good.
You could always sell, that's true.
You know what, let's sell a bunch of stuff.
Sell.
Let's sell all...
our weak things.
I'm not making much from this, but I'm making money.
A little bit.
Astro train is another triple charger.
Oh, changer.
Like Blitzwing and can turn into a steam engine and a space shuttle!
That seems a little overpowered.
Mint engine.
Lightning sword.
It's riding!
I can't sell it.
Just kidding.
Yes, I can.
Maybe freak train?
That'd be kind of awesome, not gonna lie.
Basic sniper rifle.
Okay, now we're getting more big bucks.
These are all still rank D, so I think we're on C level.
Everything that I've been using.
We have so many.
Holy moly.
Are you gonna buy some of the toys now?
Oh my gosh, I went to AmiAmi the other day and they had the cutest little plushies.
Of like Optimus and...
I know they had Bumblebee, I can't remember who else they had.
As a joke, I say you'd probably either be a combiner with Doki Bird or you'd transform into Optimus Prime's reconnaissance drone.
I wanna be my own guy.
Why is even this so expensive?
But it's rank C.
Does the rank not mean much?
Sideswipe swords.
Oh, we could just buy them.
I'm at the Japan, only characters as a combiner made up of six trained Autobots named Raiden.
There's too many options, I'm getting lost in the sauce, you guys.
Let's just keep going for now.
Let's just keep going for now, and if I die and I need to do upgrades, then we'll work on it.
Oops.
Thanks gamer!
Oh my God!
Ok, we're going.
How did I get to the other side of the bridge?
Oh my God!
Seeker!
Dang it, I tried to block.
I tried to dodge that.
Why are you always going into plane mode, every single one of you?
I'm still safe.
I'm still...
We got him.
Somehow.
Let's go.
Grab my stuff.
What is...what is this?
Enter.
There's one over here too.
I saw something else on the map.
Modeled after the ones used by Optimus Primal in Beasties.
No way!
Oh man, I lost my money.
What is this?
Oh, the side missions.
Thank you.
Just go!
Oh my gosh.
Oh no.
Oh no, he moved me.
Is there...is there a thing to make us go super fast?
Oh, this is the other one that I was seeing I think.
Look at the light here.
I almost missed this.
I almost missed that.
Can I double jump as a car?
Let's try it.
Oh no, it makes me double jump back to robot.
There we go.
No time!
Just go!
Oh my god, that's a tank.
No time!
Just go!
Go!
Ok, just kidding.
Turn around!
Just go!
Oh my god.
Oh, is everybody coming into...
Wait, I think everybody is here.
I think everybody is here.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Ouch!
Oh my god.
Wait.
Oh god.
Oh my
god, there are so many guys here.
Vehicle attack!
Just attack!
Oh my gosh.
Maybe I can get a back attack.
Back attack!
Nevermind!
I tried!
There we go.
Oh my god.
Get out of there.
Ok, we got one down.
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna die!
Ok.
Oh my gosh, that was a close one.
Back attack!
Oh god.
Oh god, my health!
Back attack, please!
I want to do it sometimes!
Ok, we got his ass.
Kind of.
Oh my god.
Wait, I'm gonna heal.
I'm gonna heal.
It's fine.
Wait, did it work?
50% of health!
Where?
That didn't work.
I clicked yes, right?
I
have the all-in chip!
Oh my gosh, you're right.
YOLO!
Oh my god.
You're so right.
I wasted it.
I slid the wrong way.
It's so frustrating.
Are you kidding me?
Wait, what's that over there?
Hold on.
Wait, there's a thing!
Ok.
How do I get this guy?
Let's see.
Throw a car at him?
Good idea.
Another car.
Excuse me.
Thank you.
Ok.
Did someone call for an Uber?
Max speed.
Hold on.
I'm gonna try and...
Oh shit.
But I don't know how to get max speed here.
Ok.
Let's try it.
That's right.
Oh no!
No!
There we go.
Ok, we got one guy down.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, there we go.
Come here.
Oh no!
Oh god.
It's like 1 HP in a dream basically.
I need him to...
There we go.
Ok.
Oh shoot.
I was hoping for the focus.
There!
Focus!
Oh my god.
Oh my ult!
Wait!
Oh it's the auto repair kit!
Oh...
Oh!
Yippee!
I can't believe it.
Oh is this a time thing?
Oh gosh.
Race motor master!
Ok.
I'm going, I'm going, I'm going.
I'll have him know that I'm pretty dang fast.
Oh shoot.
Where is it?
This way?
I'm going.
Nice.
Oh I went the wrong way!
Oh shoot.
It's pretty close you guys.
Oh shoot!
Is it not this way?
Turn this way?
Shoot.
We got this?
Oh shoot.
Oh my gosh.
Where is it?
I think I went the wrong way.
No I didn't.
We
got this!
Maybe?
Where is he?
Where am I?
You were not right behind me, huh?
He was not right behind me like that.
He was right behind.
That
was a close one.
Come on motor master!
Dang it.
Almost got the back attack.
Stupid!
I'll get him now.
Oh just kidding.
Oh shoot.
There was an attempt.
There was an attempt there.
There we go.
I think I got him.
Shot!
Back...
Oh my gosh!
The way his...the way his body is laying there.
lol
Fun!
OK What the hell is going on here?
Oh my goodness.
We're gonna go with this?
Oh my gosh.
Oh!
Gross.
OK.
What about Starscream's thing?
Insecticons easy?
Yeah but nasty.
Nice.
Oh no.
I'm low energy already.
OK.
I didn't have to get these guys but...
But...
It's OK.
And...
Get
the insignia.
How do I get it though?
Because there was the other one on the bridge.
But...
Just run backwards.
We got this.
But...
We're fine.
Probably.
Here Zeke!
Come here!
Where does he drop down?
Pick up!
I'm spamming!
Maybe over here?
Oh I got him!
OK.
Where are you Zeke?
You shoot the insignia?
OK.
Hold on.
I got to go back through here though.
Scary!
Like that?
Took down a Decepticon flag!
Unlocked a new character art for the gallery!
Oh my eyes.
Oh cool!
Thanks guys.
No idea...
That was a thing.
OK
so...
OK I...
OK sorry.
My bad.
So...
I already get lost in this city and you're going to have me...
OK this way.
Oh shoot.
I see them.
I don't have time to deal with you!
This way!
Oh!
Ouch!
Really?
Come on!
Here?
It's like right here!
Maybe I have to go up this way.
I definitely have to go up this way.
Ouch!
Oh thank you!
Something exploded them for me.
Awesome.
Oh not awesome!
That's awesome though.
OK this way.
Alright, towards the claws.
It's always towards all the danger, right?
Nice!
Oh wow!
We took it out in the last hit.
The claw...
Yeah!
OK.
Alright we are real close.
Or it's like right...
Not that.
I sure hope not.
Wait.
OK hold on before we do that.
I heard of a game called Crow Country.
I have!
Um...
Actually I haven't played it because...
I'm not so like...
It's kind of like Resident Evil style I feel.
It's not like my exact favorite type of game.
Uh oh!
Oh my god he's that meme.
The guy that slaps it on there.
Explode!
Oh OK.
Yeah we will.
Oh my gosh!
There are so many people here!
Oh my god!
Yeah!
And by we I mean me.
Me.
By me.
I mean we.
Me.
Oh my god.
Hey what are you guys doing over here?
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
What was that?
Holy hell.
What was...
Oh my god!
What was that?
That jumpscare in my own ears.
Oh my god.
That actually...
Am I in VC?
Why would I be in VC on stream?
I think you're haunted.
I can't be haunted by another ghost.
That scared me so bad.
Oh my god.
I need a break after that.
Holy moly I need an actual breather.
Poor headphone users.
That's me!
I literally threw my
head...
Starscream's ghost.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
I'm gonna turn down the volume for now.
Just in case that happens again.
And the volume on my headphones.
Oh my god.
Your PC might be a Decepticon.
Gosh.
I feel like traumatized after.
I'm like do I even wanna...
Oh my god.
Uh oh.
Warning.
An
Optimus!
I'm so freaked out now.
Oh my gosh.
Come here.
Come here with my short arms.
There we go.
Can you guys even hear the game anymore?
My heart is still pounding.
Me too.
That scared the donkadonks out of me.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, Seekers.
Sorry, I'm getting money.
They're on me.
They're on everybody.
What are you talking about?
Oh my gosh.
You guys scared me so bad.
I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry that happened.
I don't know what happened at all.
That's never happened before.
Stinking guy.
Wait, I'm gonna get all this stuff.
Look at all this loot.
Wait, what's that?
Disappeared.
They got it.
Everything's fine.
Wait, no they don't.
He's still there.
I'm coming in.
With an attack.
Saddle slam?
Excuse me?
What was that?
Oh, these guys just explode.
We don't even have to worry about them.
Oh, maybe we do have to worry about them.
Sorry.
Wait,
what?
Sorry, hold on.
Hold on.
Star stream didn't actually come back as a ghost?
That's so funny.
Oh, these guys.
Come on.
Back attack.
Ouch.
We got his ass.
Nice.
I 1v1 that guy.
Come on everyone.
What are you doing?
Tentatively turning the volume back up.
I'm very tentatively turning the volume back up because I'm scared.
I'm leaking all over.
Why am I all by myself?
Where did my friends go?
Where are my friends?
As long as I can keep dodging his stuff, I should be okay.
Maybe.
Okay, phase 2.
I like his horns.
Oh shit.
Oh, ouch.
He
can still attack you.
Oh, I'm getting his head.
Oh my god.
Oh, I can still dodge.
Even in the air.
Let's go.
Damn, I was getting good damage with his head though.
Nice.
I'm just spamming this over and over again.
Oh, I got an S on that, you guys.
Menasor!
Oh, I thought he was running away with the crying.
Um...
He's like, if I can't have it, no one can have it.
Oh, just kidding.
They have it.
Dang it!
Nobody likes Starscream.
You can make a tron, but I will laugh last.
I will laugh last.
Who says that?
Everybody says I'll have the last laugh.
Starscream, the most loyal soldier.
Absolutely.
Chapter 4 complete!
Nice, that means we only have what?
5, 6, 7?
3 more?
Menasor's Ionizer Sword!
Let's skip this.
Oh dang, this seems pretty good.
Hold on.
No mission?
I do want to synthesize some stuff.
Let's see, let's get rid of Starscream's baby stuff.
It's so much better!
I wonder if it's really... Is it slow though?
Let's go.
I do want to get some stuff up though.
I am... Hold on.
First though...
We have the all-in, right?
I feel like I should have the ability to recover.
Wouldn't we?
What does it do again though?
Increases attack at the cost of losing ability.
It's like 15% attack.
Let's try another one.
We are going to develop something.
Something great.
Something...
Ranged up attack.
15%.
These giant combiner boss fights are chef's kiss.
They are so good, right?
Just don't get hit.
So true.
Just game.
I don't think that really helps us so much though.
Not with how I play, I feel.
We have the enhanced radar.
Okay.
Synthesize.
We are going to synthesize our gloves.
Our drills.
We have...
Focus plus level 4 might be good.
Do you want to boost the difficulty?
No, I'm having fun.
So...
I'm okay actually where I'm at.
Trying to decide if I want the recovery.
Or the... Wait a second.
If we have all in...
Increases amount of health recovered.
We can't even use this.
Wait a second.
We can't even recover health.
Because we have all in equipped.
So actually this...
No.
This... Wait, wait, wait.
Yeah, we have no recovery.
So we remove this.
If we set this, increases damage dealt by 15%.
In mid-focus, which I use all the time.
Like I'm always in focus mode.
I'm locked in.
Okay.
So now I'm just gonna do some...
Like... Oh no, that's...
Not that one.
We're just gonna...
Wait.
We're just gonna synthesize with some weapons just to...
Level it up.
Level 7.
Something tells me you'd like the Autobot Warpath.
Everyone likes Warpath.
Maybe.
And then...
How is the max I can get to?
Max level.
I'm just using ones that don't have skills on them.
To level up.
That was level 8.
Maybe we're okay there.
And then...
What other...
What's my ranged weapons that I use?
Shock blast.
Oh, cryo machine?
We need to...
We can even do more skills on this actually.
Let's see.
Ult cost.
Blast plush.
Focus plush.
Oh wait, this is Starscream.
Sorry Starscream.
Defect.
Defect, what does that do?
Oh, okay.
We're adding it.
Wait!
Negative!
No, wait.
Is that actually...
Wait, that's so messed up.
Is it what it means?
It's a bad gun.
Defect is bad.
How dare the name actually be what it actually is.
How dare!
Accuracy, level 3.
We'll do that for sure.
Oh yeah.
How dare it means a bad thing actually.
Actually...
Just gonna go with some smaller things too.
Like this.
Okay, now it's level 5.
Yeah, SMH game, not lying.
How dare.
Okay.
Apparently you can get rid of the defect debuff if you fully upgrade the slots.
I see, I see, I see.
No, I've never died once even in my whole afterlife.
Ever, ever.
Must be stopped.
Megatron.
Follow me.
I haven't played as Wheeljack or actually I haven't played as Optimus Prime yet either.
But I just feel so comfortable with Bumblebee.
So I hope you guys don't mind if I keep playing as him.
Yippee!
He thinks he's Mario.
Mario.
Optimus...
Oh, okay.
Shoot.
Oh my god.
Where are you?
Stupid.
Open.
I tried dodge.
Oh my gosh, I can't see anything.
This is crazy.
Where are we?
This is so awesome.
There we go.
Nice.
I totally...
I just...
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
There we go.
I'm out.
Come on, Starscream.
How the hell did you get down there?
Nice.
Not nice.
Oh, back attack.
I tried...
How...
How are we?
Where are we?
That was so close.
Oh.
We got him.
Mess him up.
We kicked his butt.
Oh,
Starscream.
He's so pathetic.
Help me up.
What?
I'm still confused what that sound glitch was.
Auto-buckets?
Blitzwing again?
Nice.
Wait.
No, no, no.
We're not done with him.
We'll take care of one.
Maybe not one at a time.
OK.
We're fine.
We got to break these guys'...
Nice.
Where is he?
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Slide, slide, slide.
You know what?
This is fine, maybe.
No, it's not fine.
But this is fine.
This is fine, maybe.
I tried to get under his legs.
I tried to get under his legs!
Oops.
Probably an audio buffer bug.
The game glitched and played a bunch of sounds at the same time, which made them incredibly loud.
I guess so, maybe.
Can we take him home?
Cool finisher.
Sentry bot.
Actually...
Before we can...
Well, also...
This looks mighty tasty.
Oh yeah, I shoot the symbol.
Thank you!
You guys can always tell me when to shoot the symbol.
Because I will forget.
Or if I don't... I didn't even see that one.
I didn't even see that one.
But I did want to actually...
Oh, look at that!
Oh my gosh, we missed so many!
Oh no!
Oopsie.
Crimsie!
Info logs.
I wanted to hear more about the Proud Star.
Isn't there a...
Oh, there's no one to narrate this one?
OK.
My favorite cheesy line is when Megatron says, Brilliant, my Boron compressor.
Boron is a brown metal, so you can guess what it means.
Ew!
Proud Star log 000-0000-0616.
G-axis.
Who is that?
Who is this?
G-axis.
J-axis.
He's from the G2 comic book.
I'm excited for the scientific discoveries and explorations that are coming from our mission, but I would be dishonest with myself if I said that I wasn't also getting caught up in Nova Prime's mission.
Maybe it's how he carries himself, but the sheer idealism and hope that emanates from that bot is profound.
He truly is the best of us.
I'm just a scientist.
But he truly believes in the spark of Cybertron, and carrying a torch from the well of the AllSpark from planet to planet.
He believes that our accomplishments, both as species and as a society, are worthy of taking to the stars to share with others.
It makes my science seem insignificant against a mission with that much pride and legacy wrapped up in it.
Who knows, maybe I'll convert and call myself an Autobot one day.
Wow, okay.
Needs a whole lot to unpack, okay.
It's a pun on G-Access because the G2 comic was getting cancelled?
Oh my gosh, how petty.
It's my favorite.
Critics!
We set down on a planet that had no need for cyberforming, but did offer us supplies we desperately needed for ourselves.
It was shocking to see another planet so like Cybertron itself.
It was as if Primus' hand had shaped the planet.
There was no smaller life to speak of, but something must have given the planet shape.
We took the supplies we needed, but while there, we all thought someone had their optics on us.
There was, I don't know, a sense of invasiveness there.
And it has been two cycles since we left that planet and something has changed.
Innova Prime, most notably.
His confidence is still there, but it's changed.
He appears to be driven more and more each passing cycle by his own ego.
Not the righteousness of our mission, but his determination that he is right and that the work must be done.
A fear for where we are headed.
And now I truly do miss my home back in Tagan Heights on Cybertron.
There we worked and lived.
A simple life, but a good one.
We've come a long way from Lithonia?
Lithonia?
Back then, changing the planet's core and injecting it with enough raw ore-13.
There was a sense of pride and righteousness in our hard work.
But now, lost in the darkness of space, we are all succumbing to urges we never thought we'd have.
Lithone.
Jaxxus is a character from the G2 run of the comic books, who is the villain acting as a third faction.
Cybertronian?
No way.
Another role he has in IDW Publishing's comic run as an ancient transformer and scientist who acted as a mentor to Shockwave.
I really like the, like...
I don't mind, obviously, like, you know...
Megatron and Optimus' battle against each other and everything, like, that's so great.
Enemies to lovers, we love it.
But...
But, I just feel...
Like, I love the history and the origins of stuff so much more with...
With... In Transformers.
Like...
I'm just gonna, like, for example...
It's surprisingly deep.
Yeah!
There's so much, I know.
Like, for example...
In Transformers 1...
Like, when we got to the stuff involving, like, the actual, like, primes and everything...
I was just like, oh, this is kind of...
This is so way interesting.
Waiting for spoilers?
I didn't say any spoilers.
Spoilers.
It happens when you get 40 years of comics and cartoons to pull from.
True.
True!
But, how would I read the comics?
You know, is there, like, a place online to read them, rather?
Like...
I'm not super into collecting comics.
So, if there's, like, an online, like, you know...
Not anymore?
No!
A library...
It's kind of like, you know, like, reading manga online.
I don't really collect physical manga.
Unless I really, really love a series.
Or, like, an author or something.
Like, I'll collect...
Or if I'm, like, super deep in a series already.
It's kind of stinky, though.
Like, um...
I collect Junji Ito physical manga.
But...
So, the Marvel comics, you start from issue 1 and just go.
IDWs start with infiltration.
You have to go, but the paperbacks aren't too expensive.
It's also a matter of not having a lot of space for me.
I'm, like, maxed out of several bookshelves now.
I'm maxed out on several bookshelves now, so...
You know...
Luckily, they're very thin, right?
I need to stop buying doujins.
G-Axis.
Our journey grows even longer.
The search for planets that are both uninhabited...
Uninhabited.
And to have enough base material to cyberform is a long and difficult one.
None of us will talk about it, but we all can feel it.
The further from Cybertron we get, the darker our thoughts become.
The current run from Skybound Entertainment can be read online, I think.
Since it started just last year.
IDWs 2005-2017 run.
You'll have to find it online.
Oh, I see.
Thank you.
The crew is turning on itself.
For my part, I know they're after my science.
I've locked them all out, except for the ones I need for my experiments.
I can't fathom why they don't volunteer for my work.
Don't they understand it's for science?
Don't they understand that their sacrifice is for the greater good?
Despite the fact that all my equipment can't detect another ship or lifeform out there...
I am convinced that there is a will infringing upon our sparks.
Not just a will, but consciousness.
Whatever it is, we are less than insecticons to it.
And I fear that all our good work seeding worlds will come undone...
If we can't find a way to reverse its effects.
Zoo books!
Nova Prime is the only one who sees what we're doing for what it is.
Cybertron must survive.
All other considerations are irrelevant.
We will succeed, no matter the cost.
Ruh-roh.
It has come to this.
Most of the crew has been infested with whatever has taken hold of Nova Prime.
They have turned their back on our mission.
And I am the last one.
They know I will not allow them to cyberform any more inhabited worlds.
Oh, they were... oh no.
They know I will try to stop them, even if it means scuttling the ship.
But there is a way that I might be able to survive.
There is a shuttle.
It can't take me back to Cybertron, but perhaps to one of the planets we have seeded.
Perhaps I could live out the rest of my days in peace.
The horror of what I have seen.
The destructive power of both this ship and the planet we landed on.
Nothing has been the same since we landed there.
I have programmed the ship's navigation to crash.
The next time the ferrotaxis is activated, I will attempt to escape if I can.
But my odds are not good.
Oh no!
See, this is so interesting.
Kranix.
This is it.
We have come across a planet hardly worthy of us even attempting to cyberform.
It will take too much energy to convert all that mud and rock and water to a planet Cybertronians can inhabit.
But what's worse is that there is life there.
Plant life and what appears to be some kind of intelligent life.
Not mechanical, but something else.
It's glitch-inducing to look at, to be sure.
But that doesn't mean it should be destroyed.
My trap is set.
When Nova Prime and the others fire up Proudstar's cyberforming protocols, we'll launch into the planet's surface.
This will only work if J-Axis doesn't find my hidden commands in Teletran Alpha's operating system.
He is the only one smart enough to find them.
But hopefully he will be too late and I'll be on the shuttle.
I've chosen to try and make it back to Lithone.
It should be well-formed by the time I arrive.
And that was the last planet where I remember us all feeling truly proud and happy.
I could use that feeling again now.
Oh no!
The cyberforming protocols are enacted!
I have to get to the ship.
It's my only chance!
Rather than coming under a dark influence in the story, the original Nova is just a racist expansionist who believed it was Cybertron's god-given right to rule over all other inferior lifeforms.
I see.
Ah, sorry kids, I'll be hoarding.
Ok, cool.
Semii, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
And Gargou, thanks for the five gifts.
Thank you so much.
Alrighty.
Let's continue onwards.
We haven't seen this in a bit.
No!
Certain weapon types.
I don't have the correct...wait, maybe...
You!
No.
Maybe...shoot!
Ok, just kidding.
Yeah, let's do that.
Actually, yeah, sorry.
More lore!
Morph walls.
Woah!
This room is insane!
Look at all this.
Holy cow.
Oh my god.
Try the shock blaster.
Monkey!
Oh wait, what's this?
I almost missed this.
Mystery object.
See, this is the thing.
I missed one earlier before.
Oh my gosh, good thing I went back.
Vermin doll!
Every prime before Optimus was a P. No.
Optimus is too cool.
Wait, who's...
DD?
Megadoodoo?
Hello.
Shockwave.
Wait, is this my first time fighting Shockwave in this game?
Oh gosh!
He's so fast!
Oh my god, he's so fast.
Oh my god, he's so fast!
Faster than me!
Meg attack!
We will control the plasma energy.
I
don't like that.
Look at Megatron!
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna die here for real.
No!
Oh shoot.
Oh gosh.
No!
I won't let you!
Megatron cute.
I got an S on that even.
Megacombo.
DD Megacombo.
No, Decepticons?
Being deceptive?
We got the commercial break.
He's so funny!
Thank you guys for the super chat!
In the comic continuity, Shockwave is responsible for everything bad happening.
Shockwave's grey shadow clones are a reference to the Astro Magnum.
The transforming toy Hasbro brought those rights to and made into Shockwave for the original series.
I like Shockwave's design.
Yeah!
Can't stop coughing today.
Oh yeah, Shockwave's blaster.
Anything else?
Nice.
Shockwave blaster.
I'm gonna make something really awesome you guys.
The greatest thing known to man!
Grapple power up.
That would be great for Grimlock maybe.
Let's go gambling!
One more, one more, one more.
Haha!
Vehicle attack up.
Oh, this is also all in.
I feel...
Vehicle attack up could be...
Better in that, because I'm always using it.
But all in is only 10% instead of 15%.
Yeah, Bumblebee has 2 vehicle attacks, so yes.
Right?
Oh, it might stack.
Oh yeah, I wonder.
I wonder if it would stack.
But our enhanced radar, I love it so much.
All in stacks?
We're too good.
I guess we'll never know where the hidden thingies are now, but that's OK.
Hmm...
I want to see... Wait, equip?
I want to see...
We didn't even use the sword.
Wait, instead of the shock blaster, maybe...
Wait, can we use... Oh, nope, not Starscream.
Shockwave blaster?
Blaster?
What is it at now?
I think I'll switch.
I like the machine gun, because it's very fast.
OK, we can try this.
Ha!
OK.
Alright.
Actually, I am going to synthesize too, because we can get some stuff on our shock...
No, shockwave blaster.
Oh, never mind.
What is the... Hold on, I want to see what the...
Max energy... Increases max weapon energy by 20%.
OK.
Shockwave toys can be seen spray-painted and repurposed use as medical equipment props in Aliens.
What?
That's so funny.
OK, maybe we'll try it for now.
Game start-o!
That's called recycling.
Reduce, reuse, recycle.
Shockwave holding.
Oh, OK.
It's really like we are watching the cartoon.
We are getting sucked.
Wait, so we escape from the core.
The ground is gone.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, there is a timer.
No!
Come on!
Go, go, go!
Boost, boost, boost!
Oh my gosh.
I can't get up the stairs.
I can't get up the stairs!
Over there, over there, over there.
I'm so slow.
OK, there we go.
A little Bumblebee that could.
Optimus, the core is going critical.
It's gonna keep on pumping out more and more power.
Bumblebee looks traumatized right now.
Planetary extinction.
No one escapes.
The Insecticons and the Plasma Core are but two of three components.
The Ferrotaxis!
Though it contains much of our lost culture.
Oh no.
Destroying it could save Earth.
No!
Megatron has Ferrotaxi!
Uh oh.
This guy!
OK.
Go after the Ferrotaxis.
We gotta destroy our culture!
That's so sad!
Our culture!
I'm picking up all the logs!
They have our culture.
That was so close.
Oh!
Is this supposed to be a...
Oh jeez!
Oh thank goodness there was a...
There we go.
Hello?
I keep hearing it and I...
Yeah!
Nice.
I think it actually did something.
The better attack, you know?
Nevermind.
If I can't dodge though, what's the point?
Where's the other guy?
Oh here.
Got him.
I hope Soundwave is the next boss.
I just fought him.
Probably though, right?
Maybe?
Onwards we...
We parkour.
I got gooped.
I got him.
Oop!
This way?
Nice.
Oh shoot!
No more goop!
Wait, where is it coming from?
Oh up there.
I'm so bad.
I can't aim.
I can't aim!
Autobot!
Autobot needs auto-aim.
Hello Megaminto.
Hey hi!
What is this one I wonder?
What's this side mission?
Side mission.
Let's try it.
Let's see what's going on here.
Destroy everything!
In 30 seconds?!
Dare I say impossible?
Dare I say...
Impossible, impossible, impossible, impossible...
Impossible, impossible, impossible...
I can't even hit one thing!
It's impossible!
I can't even hit that!
It's basically stationary!
Stationary!
We were so close guys.
We were so close.
Don't think.
Shoot!
I hate this wall.
There!
Ouch!
Every time!
Megatron...
What do you mean what was that?
Who do you think it was?
Cargo lift.
The battle against the wall.
My actual final boss.
Oh boy.
This looks like a boss arena too.
What a jerk!
Yeah, what gives?
What gives?
Everybody's here!
Have you guys been behind me this whole time?
That's embarrassing.
Sorry for my...
Sorry.
Can I aim?
Maybe I have to get closer.
Is there like a...
What's it called?
I got it!
What am I checking?
Oh, this thing.
Hello friends!
He's looking at me.
Wait, wait, wait.
He's looking at us!
If
you want to learn more about Dreadsformers, I would recommend checking Chris McFeely's The Basics.
He has over 250 videos explaining almost everything about Dreadsformers.
250 videos.
It's gonna take me like a whole year to get through.
But thank you!
Teeny tiny baby bee.
I'm searching?
It doesn't work!
Leave it to me!
Protect Wheeljack.
I need to...
Go into...
Crazy mode.
I missed my chance!
Nice.
Back attack!
I could've done another back attack.
Hey, I'm right here!
I'm right here!
Stop trying to attack him instead!
I was right there and he was ignoring me.
What a jerk.
These guys.
Good job, Optimus.
I also shoot him.
I hit them both not bad.
Oh no, the claw!
What the?
You guys were hiding in there the whole time?
I'm trying!
I'm assisting you!
I'm assisting!
Do you need any more assistance?
Holy moly.
Where are they?
Oh you?
Oh shoot.
How am I supposed to...
Are
you good?
Oh, he's not good.
I gotta
get...
Nice!
Ok, that didn't work, but that's ok.
We still got...
Who was shooting him?
Oh, it's this guy.
Oh my god.
Ok.
My car attack doesn't really quite work.
But that's ok.
Oh, I got him.
I got his ass.
I thought I had killed him.
Phase 3?
Give me my...
My riches first?
Wait, there's another guy.
He's over here?
Oh!
Hello.
Oh, really?
You can use it?
We destroyed it?
We're too good.
Another claw.
I'm out.
Oh gosh.
Ok, hold on.
Let's try using...
No!
Nice.
Wheeljack!
Ok.
Alright, it's...
I gotta be more...
I gotta get my higher priorities.
Higher priorities.
It appears we have company.
I was not as smooth with this one as I was before, but that's ok.
Nice.
Back attack!
Ok, this guy.
Alright.
Ok, that's one.
Ah!
Shoot.
There we go.
Ok, we got him.
Ok.
Good job, guys.
Teamwork.
The music bugged.
What happened to the OST?
I'm gonna turn it down real quick, you guys, cause I'm scared.
What if the...
What if it gets really loud again?
What if it bugs again?
I wonder why it's bugging so much though.
Oh.
Oh!
Ok.
Here we go.
Oh.
I'm an idiot.
I'm so dumb.
I was already behind him!
No!
Please!
What are you doing?
Ok, I'm not bothering with you.
I'm not bothering with you.
Ok.
Attack!
Oh god.
This sounds so... This is so lame.
There's no music.
Stop living!
Oh my god.
There we go.
Ok, that's one.
Wheeljack is already at... You guys, this is so impossible.
He's already at 50% health.
No!
Get this guy some health!
I can't even sing anything.
I'm too focused.
He's just blasting away.
Ok.
Ok, phase 3.
Nice.
That was easy.
Oh, he's back to full health.
Ok, perfect.
Alright.
That's one guy.
Oh...
Ok,
that's another guy.
You?
What do you mean?
What do you mean by that?
Claws?
I'm taking care of everything else here.
Excuse me.
What claws?
Oh, that claw.
Shit.
I don't want to redo.
Please.
Ok,
he's not that on health at least.
Ok.
Oh my goodness.
That was so scary.
Oh gosh.
We good?
Everything alright over here?
Where'd you come from?
Where'd that guy come from?
For real.
Ok.
Good job everybody.
Good job.
I didn't even notice that guy.
To be honest.
I'm turning the volume back up.
Our music.
Oh my god.
Is it just me?
Am I the only one here?
Oh my god.
I'm the only one here.
I'm trying to fight.
I'm trying...
Nice.
Next!
The menu.
I think we have to go back to the main menu.
It's ok.
After this.
Nice.
See ya.
Oh shoot.
I missed my chance.
I missed my opportunity.
Ouch.
Where
are you?
There you are.
One more.
Got him.
Transformers ASMR.
I gotta go do melee on him.
Ouch, ouch.
See ya.
Yeah, we got him.
After this...
I guess we'll go back to the main menu?
Oh no!
We have music again!
Anything here?
No.
Anything over here?
The BGM is back.
Why is it so buggy today?
I wonder.
Wait, can I blow these up instead?
I should have blown those up.
Oh, it didn't even work.
That's so lame.
So lame.
Ok, more money.
Have a sneeze?
No.
Looks like my eyes are just a little bit dry.
Sentry bot, attack mode.
Where?
Where are you at?
I remember this was where we tried to do that...
Oh, it won't even let you this time.
Remember we tried to... Oh wait, will it?
I wonder.
Oh, it doesn't.
We defeated the Decepticons and took back the music, baby!
Why did I do that?
Hello?
Oh my god.
Oh, ok, it's a timed attack.
Let me do...
No, let's go...
I wonder though if it would be easier with like...
Like that.
Yeah.
Way easier.
Way,
way easier.
Boss!
I don't like that.
Ok.
Oh my god.
Ok, I can't... Oh!
Oh shit!
Give me a second!
It's so...
Oh, nice!
I missed... Oh, I got it still.
Nice.
We made it!
We're fine!
Silly sound wave.
Whoever wished sound wave to come back, you're welcome.
Here it comes, I guess.
Who's targeting me?
Is this something to search?
It is.
I did something.
Oh, I got these working again.
So I guess if we wanted to do this mission... Oh, do all this again.
I see, I see.
It's all back.
Oh gosh.
Oh shoot!
Oh no!
Oh god, am I gonna die?
Am I gonna die here?
I wish I could heal.
Oh, I think I killed all of them.
Yeah, I got them.
Kind of.
Like, most of them.
I wish I could heal!
No!
Roll out.
Is it this guy?
Yeah, it's that guy.
Got him.
There's more of them.
Okay, hold on.
We're gonna take out this.
And then we're gonna do this.
And we're gonna go in for an epic...
Where the hell did you come in?
Guys, I'm almost dead.
Guys?
Bumblebee is almost bumble done.
There's nothing over here.
Repair kit?
I can't use it!
Dang.
I can't heal while I'm in this mode.
Actually, hold on.
If we enter the arc and then leave, I wonder...
If it counts as a heal.
It should?
Awesome.
Let's see.
What if I develop one more technique?
I gotta test my luck.
And my skill.
Reversal power up.
What the hell does that mean?
I might need to go get my eye drops.
Let's synthesize our drills.
But with what?
We'll just get the power... What's it called?
We'll just get the level up.
I like using these a lot though.
But we'll keep the same skills.
Nice.
Heal.
And let's just use some of the...
The stinky weapons.
Like this one.
Oh, nevermind.
We'll use the butter weapons.
This one.
Yeah.
Those big ol' eyes have plenty of surface area for moisture loss.
Could be dry winter air with the weather.
Maybe not.
It's been cold.
Cold.
It's been cold, cold.
I can buy moves!
Did I know this?
I did know this.
I literally bought a move.
I knew this.
Bubble Beast sure likes putting his arms up behind his head.
Haha, what if Minto did that too?
Hold square, triangle, or L2.
I could buy more!
Oh, if only I had 40,000.
It's my fault for gambling.
I'm gonna give reversal though.
So Bumblebee is your character of choice?
He's just so zippy!
It's so fun to play as him, you know?
Rush combo and burnout?
What?
What about him?
I don't feel like I'd use this.
I don't feel like I'd use burnout.
Reach top speed in a vehicle mode, hold triangle, then mash it to perform a flip.
Cannot be used by Grimlock.
That's so sad.
I feel like, like I said, I go into focus so much.
Is there shove?
Quickly tilt the movement...
First of all, spin attack.
Parry.
Parry or reversal?
Rush combo is fine.
I could probably use that.
Okay, we'll get that.
And then...
Either parry or reversal.
Parry the platypus!
Yeah.
Reversal is good for you.
Parry means not dodging.
So true!
So true.
Let's do reversal.
Alright.
Hold square...
Okay, I have to hold it.
Hold square, triangle or L2.
I have to hold it.
Alright, we got some new stuff, baby!
So now we have the max speed and then I mash triangle.
And then...
Hold on.
Oh wait.
Can I sell moves?
No.
But then...
If I...
It is triangle.
Okay.
Then hold triangle.
I'm just gonna do triangle with everything so I can remember.
Let's try it.
Energon cubes.
Meow.
Wait, my dramatic entrance.
Soundwave!
A darkness fell over him.
Burrowed in time.
Something corrupted him.
Driving him mad.
He did come here to destroy Earth.
But only after encountering some singular entity.
Something bent not just on destruction.
But our destruction.
And Nova Prime sent it in our direction.
It's out there now.
Searching and destroying its way to Cybertron.
Nova Prime?
One of our own?
Really went bad on us?
It appears so.
Teletran-1, find us a way to the control room.
This cargo lift can be used to reach the control room.
I do not have enough access to tell you how to operate the platform, however.
Okay.
Oh, just shoot it.
So true.
That should do it.
Yeah!
Oh boy.
Uh-oh.
This is not good.
Smash, smash, smash, smash!
Oh, dang it.
I missed it.
Yeah, you know what?
I will do that.
It's back attack!
Wait, I forgot to hold.
Oh?
Thank you.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, I'm getting thrown everywhere.
I'm getting thrown everywhere!
Oop!
Give me my stuff!
Ah, dammit.
I tried to do the new attack.
Hold on, let's try it again.
Dang it.
Oh gosh.
What weapon am I using right now?
What was I using?
It was... Oh, the sword.
We will arrive any moment now.
And Megatron is waiting for us.
Be ready for anything.
No, Soundwave is fine.
He's alright.
He's just... you know.
He's cool.
Oh my gosh, that was chapter 6?
And I got an A.
Last chapter everybody.
Last chapter.
Let's go!
Loudspeaker!
Mess him up, Mito.
Sorry I haven't been doing much of the side missions.
I just...
I'm not good at them.
It's a really good gun, isn't it?
Let's equip it.
Maybe we'll use that instead of the cryo gun.
Where is it?
Oh, Loudspeaker.
Let's, um...
Synthesize!
You can sunlock enemies with it, but short range.
Ok, short range weapon.
I see, I see, I see.
Transformers has crossed over with my My Little Pony and also my Mazinger Z.
Wait, Transformers has crossed over with My Little Pony...
I feel like Mazinger makes sense though, right?
I built giant robots.
When Grimlock was first created, he was so primitive, he and the other Dinobots...
Turned on their creator.
They literally had to upgrade his brain to get it functioning like a normal person.
My Little Pony also makes sense too though, because it's Hasbro.
Right?
He's a communications officer and spy master.
He doesn't really fight much, except in the Prime show, where he took a vow of silence and whooped butt.
One of Soundwave's most popular ships is with Hatsune Miku.
That's so beautiful.
That's beautiful.
Let's do...
Is knockdown just for like...
Oh wait, my bad.
Loudspeaker letters.
Is knockdown just for melee weapon?
Wait, I want to know what it is.
I want to know what it is.
Let's see.
Accuracy fire rate.
Oh no, this is my... I don't want to get rid of it just yet.
Bolt cost.
We'll do this.
Synthesizing.
Oh, I have to be careful though.
Oh, synthesis 101.
I got a trophy.
That's cool.
I have to be careful though of my money.
We'll give it one more.
Maybe like... What do I have on it right now?
Bolt cost.
OK.
What's over... Oh no, that's...
Focus plus.
We'll do this one.
Yes.
Alright.
I'm going to miss having so many shots, but whatever.
I just have to get good.
How many...
It doesn't say.
Alright.
Let's go.
Get good.
We're going to be a gamer.
It hardly matters now.
Decepticons keep them busy.
We've almost won.
We are almost there.
Time to crash the party.
Oh yeah.
Look how cool comm collective we look.
Is it a controversial opinion if I say that I'm not really super fan of this Megatron's voice?
Is that a controversial opinion?
Oh.
Oopsie.
Oh, I did kill him.
Just kidding.
No.
Yeah, I know it's the original VA, so I'm not like...
I'm not like, oh, it's the worst ever.
I just feel, you know...
Nice.
Oh, OK.
So easy.
Easy.
I just imagine always Megatron to have more of a deeper, like...
Yes.
You know, kind of voice.
This voice has ruined me, maybe.
OK, we don't want to waste it.
Everybody...
Just stop.
You can hear them behind me.
You guys, just avoid it.
Nice.
Maybe not nice.
Why am I not on my drills?
Oh gosh.
I think we got him.
I didn't have to do anything.
Yay.
No.
Let's get our cash money, baby.
Repair kit.
Just kind of useless to me, but that's OK.
Hold on, I'm getting my money.
Get my money.
OK.
Stand back, everybody.
I've got this.
I missed one.
You're welcome, though.
It's a bit dated.
That's why Frank Welker updated in Transformers Prime.
His best work IMO.
I like to think it was an F you to Michael Bay for not casting him as Megatron in the first three movies.
Oh, maybe.
Wah!
Who am I fighting?
Motor Master!
Oh no, am I going to have to fight the transformed ones again?
I can't...
Shoot.
Oh, that didn't work.
Oh, come on.
It's so fast.
It's so awesome watching Optimus fight.
Just a few more.
Oh, just kidding.
I didn't do so hot with that one.
That's OK, though.
That's OK.
It's alright.
Oh my god.
We've taken all of what he's worth.
Take everything that he owns.
Where are they?
Those Seekers?
I keep forgetting the focus attack that we have to do.
Hold on.
There we go.
It's hold, right?
Oh, shoot.
We were still in...
I'm holding!
It didn't work!
I think I did it wrong!
I did it wrong.
Oh, shoot.
Oh my goodness.
I wish I could heal right now.
You guys do everything.
I'll just collect the money.
It has to be the first thing you do.
OK.
So I focus and then I hold triangle.
Onwards!
Oh, I missed one.
Mew!
I lived.
This is not the time to be so nonchalant, I think.
Holy cow, there is so much stuff on the field.
Grab it all, you guys!
What are you doing?
There is so much money here!
Grab it all!
We are losing our cash!
They are like, Bumblebee, what are you doing?
I'm doing what... Who pays for these upgrades?
It's me!
What's this?
Yes!
OK.
Yeah!
I don't think I should be here.
Oh shoot.
Dang it.
I'm doing my job now, this time.
I did my job a little bit.
Oh, were we supposed to go that way?
Mysterious.
Were we supposed to come here first?
Well, I just wanted the S and the money.
Alright, Bumblebee.
Collect our riches and...
Roll out!
What is this spell?
What did we get?
We got M?
Don't tell me it's transformers.
Everybody here?
Nobody got hurt, right?
I'm pretty hurt though, I'm not gonna lie.
That wasn't at you, don't worry.
It does spell transformers?
Would you be shocked if it is?
I would think... I thought... I don't know actually.
Goodbye everybody!
Oh, that was so lame.
Dang it!
You are right in front of me.
Good job guys!
Wow!
What's great is that the team really holds their own, huh?
It spells Mintoes.
Obviously.
I might though.
Optimism ain't looking so hot for me.
It ain't looking so good for me.
Just go!
Oh, I'm so dead.
Hi Thundercracker!
Where is everybody?
I'm dead.
I wonder where the last checkpoint was.
Which one is this?
Oh ok, we are so good.
Oh yeah!
Damn, I almost had him locked... trapped in a loop!
Oh my god and he dodged it!
I did it though!
I did it!
Nice!
Collect everything.
Where is he?
Minto wins by doing nothing.
Minto wins by doing nothing!
Where is his stuff?
I took care of the other guy though, pretty much.
Nuh-uh, he did a flip.
So true.
Alright, let's keep going.
Oh my gosh, we were so close to an arc point.
I could have just saved in here.
Or healed.
Actually, I'll be right back.
One second you guys, I'm going to go grab my up-drops.
I'm going to grab my up-drops!
One second.
Skip.
Nevermind, I don't know where they are.
Not where I thought they were.
Just kidding.
Oh my gosh, I found them!
We also have pies in here.
She really wanted a cookie?
Earlier I heard something fall into a...
I have like a little basket of snacks on my computer for when I'm really hungry.
I heard something fall into it earlier.
I was like, what was that?
Must have been the wind.
But it was my up-drops.
Little did I know.
It would be something so important.
Trash talker like a mean girl.
What?
It's a legitimate swear word for a trash talker.
Slag.
I've never heard of that before.
I don't remember.
It's been a long time since I watched Beast Wars.
Okay.
Alright, let's continue.
It's brash.
Oh, it's brash?
Alright.
Onwards.
There he is!
This is it!
Oh, I already saw the mission.
Ultimate victory.
Remaking Slag means a woman who is easy.
They are talking about robots with that.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
The Constructicons.
All of them?
Oh, shoot.
I forgot to...
Which one of you is the dick man?
They are all so strong.
Oh, dang it.
I keep missing.
Oh my gosh.
So close!
Oh, shit.
I'm doing my part!
Turn into scrap!
Holy moly.
I've taken out a good couple of them, huh?
No!
Got his little back attack.
Oh, damn!
I'm saving my ult, though.
Well, I guess I could have used it.
At this point.
Damn.
How many are left?
No!
Wait.
I'm trying to...
Oh, wait.
I can't use it.
Okay.
That's fine.
I was trying to use my ult, but it won't let me.
Oh, now it's ready.
It just wasn't ready.
I'm stupid.
Throw, throw, throw, throw, throw!
Phase chill.
This is so unfair.
Oh my god.
I can't see anything.
I don't know what's happening.
Oh god.
Oh my gosh.
I went.
Oh, I didn't do it fast enough.
That's my bad.
Oh my gosh.
Both at the same time!
This is so evil!
Oh no.
Oh no, no, no.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Nice!
Okay.
Oh, why is this camera angle so evil?
Actually, I can do that too.
And I'm out.
I timed that perfectly.
Nice.
Nice dodge.
Thank you.
I think this is it for him!
Kill him with his own drills.
You guys, I got...
You'll never believe what score I just got for that.
That was the hardest fight in the game.
Well, I'm on easy, so you know.
I'm on easy.
What did you get?
I got SS!
I killed him.
Phew.
Sexy style!
Oh sorry, I'm not... I make it look like I'm on easy.
Thank you Joey for the pig!
Ah, he says no.
Optimus has no chill.
I kind of love that.
Holy moly.
Optimus!
I mean, Megatron!
We can be buddies!
Oh shoot.
No!
Damn, he's insane.
Where is he?
There he is.
Oh my god!
Nice.
Holy...
Oh my gosh.
I need to remember the new attack that I...
Oh, this.
No!
I missed it!
There we go.
Oh, I think he dodged it too.
I'm trying to hold triangle, but I think I... Oh shoot.
Oh, I should have gotten a back attack.
What am I... I totally wasted that.
Wee!
What's great is you can just continuously dodge with those moves.
Not
this one again.
Get stunlocked, Megatron!
Oh my god!
This is so sad.
I'm cheesing my way to victory.
With 1 HP!
And a dream!
Oh my god.
He's insane.
He's gone insano style.
He went insano style!
No!
Is it phase 2 time?
I did kind of bully him.
I'm sorry.
Or?
Yeah, phase 2?
In space?
Are we actually fighting in space?
No way.
Oh no way!
I feel bad playing as Bumblebee.
I am Optimus!
Oh my...
Oh my god, this is so awesome.
How do you do that?
How do you go so far down?
Oh my god, this is so awesome.
Wait, what am I pressing?
Yeah!
Oh my god!
Why is it so awesome?
Megatron
Well that's what we said we would have to do earlier anyway.
Right?
Old man fist fight.
I totally thought it too.
They just drop dead?
Gross!
Who's going to clean this up?
Aww...
Yeah, where are all the humans?
Ok bye!
Oh they're Earthlings!
This is their home!
I'm tearing up.
Oh!
It's so beautiful!
I doubt that General Zod will have any friends.
That's our job.
Oh
my god.
Let's go.
That was mean.
I did that.
Stop.
These are such awesome visuals.
I loved this room.
Oh my gosh, it was so awesome.
Yeah!
This is like Jam Project.
It does feel like Jam Project.
The
cutscene is 100% product placement.
I mean, Transformers is basically product placement.
It's just awesome.
Transformers!
I feel like I could definitely play this game.
Maybe now on like a normal or higher difficulty.
Look at this!
Oh my god!
It's so awesome!
Hi Didi!
Didi!
86 movie watch along.
Maybe once I get back from Japan we can.
Sometime in March we shall.
This game is so sick.
It's so awesome.
Your dodges were clean.
I just wonder how much was it because of, you know, easy mode.
So I'm curious if I play on higher difficulty.
Because, you know, I do get caught in a lot of combos.
In normal with heels you can totally do it.
Yeah, and I play with no heels.
So you know what?
Honestly, no heels is like normal mode.
Really glad you got to play the game.
I'm a fan of Devastation.
I used to play the hell out of it but maybe you'll be able to complete all the challenges unlike me.
I don't know Ryu.
I mean Ed.
Ed Ryu.
I don't know.
I don't think I'm strong enough.
But overall, like I said, the first stream, the game is just so smooth feeling.
It feels so fun to play.
It's a lot of fun.
Optimus falling from space is easy mode.
Megatron took a face to a nuke powerful enough to knock the planets over.
Hope you're able to find some Transformers figures while in Japan.
Maybe, yeah.
I mean, not maybe.
I'm sure there's tons.
Doesn't feel like a vibe.
Salkin, thank you!
You've come very far from the Transformers game on the NES.
The one that's... Wait.
Hold on.
What is it?
Transformers no Nazo or whatever the hell that Transformers Nazo game is.
Just hoping this starts you on the path of Transformers brain rot till all are one.
Thank you!
Convoy no Nazo!
Oh my god.
Convoy no Nazo, please.
I've already been through enough with any Nazo games.
Super Kusoge.
Look at all these repeating names.
That's crazy.
Oh, Steve Blum!
You guys were right.
So good.
Also, since I've been watching Transformers Prime, it's very weird seeing Optimus with a mouth in that game.
Or, sorry, in that show.
So seeing him without a mouth here just feels right.
This design is so pink.
I don't like it with the mouth.
I don't have anything to add.
Just stand.
Sky bike.
Mankey, mankey, mankey, mankey...
Ruttro!
Ruttro.
Was there supposed to be a sequel to this or what?
I got the trophy!
Till all are one.
Sequel baiting.
Sting like a bee.
Must be because I played mostly Rumblebee.
Look at that!
I got SS on one of them.
Why didn't I rank in 5?
Oh, is it because I died?
Probably.
To be continued.
Right?
Got a Megatron in the corner of the screen.
Fusing cannon.
Star Saber!
Nice.
Can I... If I...
Oh, wait.
My finger actually slipped.
Wait, my finger actually slipped.
Hold on.
Skip?
Main menu.
Do I have everything though?
Oh yeah, I do.
I have all my...
So it is like a new game plus.
Nice.
Okay, main menu.
Time to check the art.
That's exactly what I was thinking.
Character models.
Hold on, the music is so loud.
DLC?
Too cool.
I think though, out of all the designs...
Even though I like Rumblebee's little...
What's it called?
His little horns.
Wheeljack might be one of my favorite designs.
I really like that he kind of looks like...
Change form?
He looks like...
He looks like he could be Rex as a Transformer.
Like Metal Gear Rex.
I really like his design though.
Cute!
So cute.
Yeah!
Gold bug.
Poinsettia.
Shockwave.
What are you turning into?
Again?
I always wish we got a sequel with a playable Decepticon campaign.
But it was never meant to be.
Until All or One Minto.
That would have been so peak.
What's try me?
All Autobots inferior, Soundwaves superior.
I can't.
Go little guy.
Just has a little man living inside him.
Little men.
Eject.
Blitzwing.
Cool.
Thundercracker.
I also really like Thundercracker's design.
It's so beautiful.
It's so clean.
Make them listen to my mixtape.
They'll die of cringe.
Can't beat the frenzy.
Oh boy.
Oh god, this guy stinks.
Laserbeak.
This is the one...
Inside Soundwave, right?
One of them at least.
Yeah, yeah, there he is.
Buzzsaw.
Ravage.
Why are they all just cassette tapes?
What?
What did he say?
Oh, because Soundwave is a boombox.
Oh my gosh, that makes so much sense.
That makes so much sense.
So cool.
I like all the Constructicons too.
They're so cute.
They're just little workers.
He's like, I mix concrete.
I haul dirt.
I dig!
They're so funny.
This guy is actually the most deadly.
Hook.
One time I joked with my friends at the theater when we saw a Transformers ad.
I said, hear me out Megatron though, as a joke.
Now my friends won't ever let me down for that awful joke.
Joke?
Oh my god, the music changed.
I love when Menasor... Oh my god, the music is so awesome.
When he breaks apart into all the little cars.
I like when he does that.
Whoa.
Why does he look like an old man?
He looks old.
I don't like him.
He looks like an old guy.
Many cars combined into a big car.
This guy.
The Seekers.
Seeker seeds.
So cool.
Kickback.
Be gone Insecticon.
Get me out of here.
I'm just a bug.
Scrapnel is such a great name.
Roll out!
Yeah!
So good.
Time to dance with the bee.
What if he said, so you like jazz?
Mr. LBZ, thank you so much for the 10 gifted.
Donald's toy looking butts.
No!
I kinda, yeah.
The harder they fall.
I don't break rules.
I bend them.
A lot.
Grimlock!
Grimlock has a great design too.
Me munch metal.
Grimlock no bozo.
Grimlock king.
Grimlock, Dinobot leader.
Slag and sludge do what Grimlock say.
Lizard.
This one looks pretty much the same.
Megatron.
Alrighty guys.
This is so fun.
Wait, ending movie, no credits.
Oh, we gotta look at the art too.
I forgot.
Sorry, my bad.
We looked at this one.
We looked at that one.
Room.
The hallways.
More of the hallways.
Concept art.
Oh wait, no.
Those are like the doors I gotta open.
Oh, these are the... Oh, these are not the hallways.
These are the... What's it called?
The runways that I was on.
Maomao!
Thank you so much for the buy hint!
Is there only really stage art of the first day?
Well, I guess there's this.
We have this.
That looks so awesome.
Oh my gosh, what a visual.
God, it's so awesome.
It's so awesome.
Looks so good.
Character art.
Oh my gosh!
I'm locked off.
I'm locked on.
Oh my god.
This seems too intimate.
Oh my gosh.
It's just like those... Oh my... Animorphs!
It's an Animorphs title or cover.
Probably.
Look at them shoes!
Golly!
What the hell?
Animorphs roll out!
Awesome.
Love the character art.
Scene art.
Who's the big guy all the way in the back?
Like the big, big guy.
Hero's world.
Omega Supreme!
Oh, hi Pies!
You want out?
What are you looking at me for?
What are you getting on my desk for?
Come here.
You want out?
You wanna try and make it up here?
You think you can?
Pies.
She's jumping around on my little table.
You wanna try?
You want in my lap?
She does not want in my lap.
Come here.
Come here!
Stop.
No.
She tries to get on my pachislot.
You
want my lap and you're gonna immediately leave.
She's so sweet.
OK, bye.
She's not a lap cat even though that's what I was advertised when I...
Cat scam.
I did get scammed a little bit.
It's OK.
Generations are...
Oh yeah!
I was looking at this stuff last stream.
Oh my god.
To the unassuming eye.
To the untrained eye of just a truck.
Just a truck.
This is such a fun game to watch you play.
Congrats on beating it.
Thank you!
Mine don't do laps either.
The 20 pound cat always wanna be held like a freaking man baby though.
There are actually anamorph toys under the Transformers brand.
Stop!
Transformers is like everywhere though.
Transformers Devastation with Metal Gear Rising and Sonic Frontier's music edits fit so perfectly together.
Is your name Megamint or Mintotron?
I feel Mintotron probably works better a little bit.
Oh my god!
Hello?
Who is this?
Mintotron.
Minta Megadoodoo.
What the hell is this?
Optimus Maximus.
Oh my god.
The jet on the leg.
The double jets on the leg.
It goes so hard.
It's too awesome.
Look at that dashing smile as he knees that guy to the face.
Too good.
Now he's serious.
Oh gosh.
I guess we got a bunch of Bumblebee art because I played so much as him.
Wait.
Who is that?
God is good sad.
Is that Grimlock?
Oh I see the little hands.
Oh my god!
That's so good.
That's such an awesome picture.
I wonder who the artist is for these.
Fan art.
Very serious Grimlock.
He is serious.
He means serious.
Grimlock on a diet.
Look at your thighs looking a little bit skinny there buddy.
He can't be all muscle.
He's gotta be a little limber.
He's like...
She's like, did I do that?
This picture though.
There's somebody crying about their home being destroyed and you're smiling Bumblebee!
A family literally lost their home and you're smiling!
Killing!
You enjoy all the killing.
I think that... wait.
Hold on.
I wanted to look at this one again.
This one is so cool.
With the dead bodies scattered around.
Smiling in front of death.
I think that's everything then.
Nice!
This was so much fun you guys.
Wait, play history.
Transformers.
Collectibles!
Wait, hold on.
Sorry.
Collectibles.
What did I collect?
Oh yeah, that's right.
I missed so many of them.
And the Decepticon flags.
Many, many collectibles missed.
My play history.
That's embarrassing.
I got 41% out of collectibles though.
Missions completed 90%.
Does that not count the side quests maybe?
Don't look at the 51%!
Zero parries.
I didn't unlock parry.
That's why you guys, I didn't even buy it.
You guys, I didn't buy parry.
How would I have any parries?
We didn't buy it!
We didn't buy the parry!
Top Mr. M, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Too poor to parry.
Come back when you're a little richer.
Who's by parry?
That's parry the platypus on AO3.
I don't get why Hot Rod was promoted to status of prime over Ultra Magnus.
Well, I couldn't tell you literally anything.
I couldn't tell you anything.
All hail Lord Mitochide!
Wisps transform and rise up!
Oh, that's spoilers?
Don't worry guys, I'll forget.
I erased it from my brain.
I literally took the piece.
I reached into my ectoplasm.
I took the part of my brain that remembered that specific super chat and I chucked it.
It's literally gone.
And now I have a goopy ectoplasm mess on my floor.
Yeah, what super chat?
You didn't need to parry.
Mito2Gamer.
I dodged!
I like dodging.
I like doing a little roll.
But yeah, this is so fun you guys!
Also, are those hurricanes?
Thank you guys for more transformers.
I know so many people have asked about the other games.
Eventually I would like to.
I do not have them.
So, playing them might be difficult.
I think they are very expensive now.
But I would like to play them in the future.
Yeah,
we'll see.
We'll see if there is any way that I can ever...
Sometimes I ask friends if they have anything too so I can borrow stuff.
So, you know, somebody might have something.
Who knows?
Going to Japan for my birthday this May!
First time!
Oh my gosh, Requiem!
I had the best time ever!
But yeah, thanks for the super chat, Saltine.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you, TriPrincess earlier.
Sorry, I didn't catch the donut.
And Kvarn!
Oh, we were getting you minky during the cutscene.
Thank you so much for the donut.
Hopefully Hasbro gets its licensing together and you can experience more for Cybertron.
Transformers Armada on the PS2 is fun too.
Have a look into it.
Otsumito, everybody!
Otsumito had so much fun and I hope you guys did too.
And we'll do more Transformers thingies in the future.
Maybe we could do like a double feature.
Maybe we could do the 86 movie and then Transformers 1.
We could have the old and the new.
Maybe we could do a double feature for those who haven't seen the first one or those who haven't seen the new movie.
Any interest in the Fist of the North Star game made by the studio that makes the Yakuza like a dragon game?
I don't know Fist of the North Star so much.
But I, you know, maybe one day.
I never say never.
I never say never to most games at least.
Otsumito, thank you guys and I'll see you next time.
Next time, next time.
Thank you for streaming.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Yeah, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye.
This is so much fun.
So, so, so much fun.
This game is so fun.
Otsumito, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye.